welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Immortals of avian just dropped a
new Gameplay trailer for their new
upcoming Magic first person shooter and
it looks absolutely insane so let's
check this Beast out together shall we
because I am beyond excited for this new
spin on the FPS genre from ascendant
Studios and of course major thank you to
Electronic Arts for sponsoring this
video and to ascendant Studios for
letting lead combat designer of
Immortals of avium Jason hornkey to
spend some time with us to talk about
this game very chill dude and I love
talking to him so let's get into it
alright so in this Gameplay trailer for
immortals of AVM Jack zandara and Devin
are about to embark on a super Dangerous
Mission directly into a massive magic
disrupting storm full of lethal enemies
but listen I'm easily Sandstorm ain't
nothing for the Lucian Army's Elite
attack Squad known as The Immortals I
mean they got Gina Torres as general
kirken leading the team so if you've
seen Gina on Firefly you know this lady
means business get prepped for a combat
drop
thank you
like I freaking love how they all summon
their sigils at the same time when
zendara yells sigils up that's how you
know that's one synchronized team but
hey if you don't already know about
these magic wrist ones that are at the
center of combat for immortals of abium
my boy Jason has got you covered it's a
piece of technology that they've
developed that allows them to focus the
magic inside of them to create forms of
uh powerful spells Immortals of avium is
all about thinking on your feet as you
learn to master three types of spells on
a chaotic cinematic War Adventure Blue
Magic called Force magic green magic
called life magic and red magic called
chaos magic we know all about chaos
magic over here each with their own
primary and heavy fire spells as well as
control spells that manipulate your
enemies in crazy ways like you can even
slow down time in one of the Spells
freaking dope in each of these magic
color types bring their own unique
battle flavor to the battle table that
encourages players to be creative and
think of sick combos of magic abilities
to completely and violates your Fierce
enemies a form of magic comes from the
Caster so the way that the the ellucians
and most of the enemies you see in the
game today uh present their magic is
through these different uh archetypes so
blue is about shields it's about
powerful protection and railgun style
headshot Precision with their their blue
bolts or their um okay yeah those are
the in the gameplay I was like all right
this one's fast I dig it yeah Mouse and
keyboard's really probably gonna go for
blue you know okay red is about big wide
swaths of chaotic energy that bathes
over a battlefield and uh protection
self-protection so armor you'll see a
lot of red characters get up in The Fray
we call them the Berserkers often uh
because they get in into your face they
do as much damage as possible they want
to do is they want to get as close to
you as they can to do as much damage as
possible it's chaos magic so it's in the
name it's like I want to do some damage
and the green is all about uh life and
death and evasive uh running gun
gameplay so it if you're going green
you're probably blinking a whole bunch
you're casting a rain of these little
homing projectiles in the air you're
assaulting someone with a artillery
strike spell called torrent wait so you
mentioned blinking what's blinking about
yeah uh Immortals of avium has two
different defensive Spells at uh Jack's
fingertips one of them is a powerful
Shield as I mentioned it's blue it's
force it protects you from incoming
damage and off of the B button off of
the circle we can blink so that's a
short range teleport and depending on
how you spec to your character you might
actually have three or four teleports if
you find all the right stuff which
allows you to be super evasive but if
you're specializing into blank you're
probably not specializing into armor so
you might have to be careful where you
get hit we are a single player narrative
shooter so our primary mode our only
mode is uh the narrative campaign uh we
have explored a lot but this is what
we're releasing and we're excited to
release it soon dude I'm all about
single player Shooters like I love a
good story and like judging by The
Cinematic trailer like I just love all
these characters already I feel like we
have a really great cast of like main
characters that we we're following I'm a
big fan of um zandara uh I'm a big fan
of that character she's already my
favorite character I'm definitely going
to be uh doing a chaos build in honor of
zandara yeah zendar is awesome the cast
is incredible our writers are incredible
Michael Crick bread has brought
um some dialogue that I wasn't expecting
to a game like ours and it's it's
excellent so like this is like a major
passion project for you absolutely I
mean I I say it around the office as a
joke but it's kind of true I hope people
like this game nearly as much as I do
dude I I love seeing developers like
actually put their heart and soul into a
game because that's you that's how you
know it's gonna be one of the good ones
foreign
what type of abilities are there that
better attach these magic types like
because I noticed Jack using like magic
whips at some point to quickly maneuver
around the area so you have three
different control Spells at your
disposal one of those as you saw in the
trailer is this powerful lash it travels
forward grabs an enemy either pulls them
to you or pulls you to them depending on
the size of the enemy which is very good
for maneuverability or if you're playing
a red Berserker like I play you want to
get in their face travel the distance
get in their face boom right in their
face move on to the next enemy and the
last uh spell that we have is the Limpet
spell which sprays a bunch of these
little Globs on enemies and slows them
down in time so that you know gives you
an advantage over them the third spell
is a disrupt spell which is on demand
singles Target stun which also forms as
a spell break it's a counter spell so if
you see an enemy casting you time that
well Kaboom it feels good and in
addition to sigil strike attack spells
Immortals of AVM will allow players to
use augment spells that change your
movement abilities and give you new ways
to interact with the environment as well
as limited use fury spells that are more
powerful than sigil strike primary fire
spells and are powered up with
consumables but out of all the Spells my
personal favorite so far are the
Dominion ultimate spells that Channel
all three magic color types to help you
absolutely delete those silly soldiers
of evil that stand in your way like a
bunch of stupid idiots like do they not
know who you are you're Jack you're a
Treyarch Magnus you've got a face tattoo
you're a man with truly nothing to lose
so we have have one what we call
Dominion spell dominions are our
ultimates that one is called immolates
it is a beam of hyper focused magic of
all three colors it shreds through
enemies armor it shreds these enemies
Shields and it shreds through enemies
it's uh that's what I like to hear in my
games shredding technique that's all I
need I want to shred through their flesh
to get them out of my sight I'm all
about it this actually if you don't mind
is a a pretty good segue into a sub uh
system in our game called shred so uh
the primary thing about our game is is
the core element of our game is about
choosing spells that you like focusing
on those getting talents that builds out
your your playstyle and then gear that
supports a playstyle also but the the
sub level the next tier down and
difficulty is enemies have a defensive
spell of the appropriate color so you
have a shield Shield's total it's a
bubble it protects them fully uh we have
chaos armor which is red as I mentioned
uh red is about getting in close so they
cover themselves in armor getting close
reduces all the damage that they take
take in perpetuity and then you have
regen so then enemy can cast a region on
themselves to heal or a Magnus might
cast region on a whole bunch of enemies
and have them constantly heal and Shred
is a concept in our game that counters
that so a little bit of Simon says if
you see a dude with a blue a blue
defensive spell you want to switch to
Blue wreck that down and then move back
to your play style we want to keep
players cycling spells we want you to
experience the different magic colors
but also we want to make sure that
combat is diverse uh Dynamic right and
exciting at all times that's what I
noticed about like both these trailers
is that like you're just constantly
flicking through the different magic
types because you're just thinking on
the fly to address the specific type of
enemy that you're fighting and I'm like
it's it's left it's more like of a
thinking game than like your regular
first person shooters which I love I'm
like yes I need to give me something
like strategic give me something that I
have to think about
um that gets me very like engaged in the
game which I I this is going to be super
amazing I love on the flight tactics
very important to us yeah
so like I'm assuming that there's going
to be ways to level up our magic in this
game absolutely yes leveling up is
really important to us we have two
primary Mechanics for leveling up we
have our Canon you collect our Cannon
off of enemies you find it in chests you
get it off of bosses enough Arcanum
allows you to get a Ascension which is a
top wedge essentially and a talent we
have a talent tree with has 81 points
and those allow you to specialize either
into a spell school in general or
specific spells and so our game is not
about getting every Talent Point our
game is about getting uh focusing into a
color you like a couple spells you like
figuring out a build and then
specializing a subset of something else
so if maybe if you're playing red you
might Splash into green so you have more
blinks you know getting close but still
be evasive maybe you're going full blue
so you want that Turtle sniper shot but
you still need a little bit of armor
when your Shield goes down so you go
blue splash red it's it's very exciting
dude I love that because like it sort of
encourages like multiple playthroughs of
the campaign because it's like all right
I did a blue build last time so now I'm
gonna go red let's see how that goes so
like I love that so much like you you
customize your own wizard I freaking
love that so much it's gonna be no
customization is really important guys
Motors of AVM also allows you to enhance
and manipulate your spells with magic
rings enchant all of your spells and
equipment with magic totems and upgrade
your passive abilities and stats with
Mystic bracers however one of my
personal favorite parts of this
Immortals of AVM Gameplay trailer were
the dungeon puzzles that players will
have to solve as they progress through
the game and I was super excited to ask
Jason about those too I noticed that
there was a lot of like puzzle elements
in the in this game like the Gameplay
trailer had some like very zelda-esque
it seemed like all right solve this
puzzle in this room type of deal like is
that going to be like a main
um staple of this game absolutely yeah
we uh we wanted to keep it from being a
you know nine hour adrenaline rush we
want to have right have the moment to
explore um while working on Call of Duty
we call these like you know uh
walkthrough moments we wanted to have
you fight through space moving in area I
see something beautiful but also then
you discover a puzzle to get through
that door you must solve this puzzle you
must figure out this traversal bit uh so
yeah that's according theme to another
game combat traversal and puzzles what
would you say like is the element that
you're the most excited for players to
experience in Immortals maybe that's
hard I've been doing this for almost
five years now like uh oh wow that's
your baby I'm the artist who sees all
the paint who never made it to the
canvas but also the game the painting is
beautiful
um and so I'm really excited every time
I watch a reaction video I've actually
seen yours as well every time I watch a
reaction video I hear these like you
know uh seeing the facial reactions When
The War Beast comes out of the wound and
eats that poor Soldier as he's about to
fall to his death anyway
um every time someone like uh during the
little teaser there was a little bit of
a lash onto a lash point which sent you
know the player flying in the air and
then you know they return fire down out
of the air like
it's just I just want to see what people
like I don't know what that is yet I
want them to speak everything and you
know as a as an ex Call of Duty zombies
designer as well I am also excited to
see who finds the Easter eggs and there
are a lot of scenes in our game oh like
we had to do rock stars level good
Easter egg so like we're gonna be
hunting we're gonna be hunting hard all
right well Jason thank you so much for
spending time with us talk about this
amazing game Immortals of avium is
coming up very soon you guys need to
pre-order like prepare to pre-order do
what you gotta do to play this amazing
story because this game like I love a
game that subverts like the expectations
of like a genre and this is like the
ultimate magic FPS that I've always
wanted to play so thank you thank you
for putting your heart and soul I can't
wait to hear what you guys think yes
this is going to be amazing I'm so
excited thank you Jay super spending
time with us talk about this in
Immortals of avian buy it immediately
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
Mass retainment on Twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some really weird
stuff and really fun theories but most
importantly you can follow new rockers
wherever we are on the social medias and
again do not forget to pre-order
Immortals of avium as soon as you can
because that game is coming out very
very soon like only in a few months and
we thank EA again for sponsoring this
video you guys are amazing
[Music]
foreign